no animal perhaps can hate itself except
of course a human being it's one of the
strangest and most regrettable flaws in
our condition this tendency to
self-hatred is not only destructive of
our spirit it constantly undermines our
efforts to establish workable
relationships for it is logically
impossible to allow anyone else to love
us insofar as we remain obsessed by the
thought of our own loathsome Natures why
let another think better of us than we
think of ourselves if anyone did step
forward and tried to be kind to us we
would have to despise them with the
intensity owed to all false flatterers
it therefore turns out that one of the
central requirements of a good
relationship is surprisingly a degree of
affection for our own Natures built up
over the years largely in childhood we
need a legacy of feeling very deserving
of love in order not to respond obtusely
and erratically to the affections
granted to us by adult Partners without
a decent amount of self-love the love of
another person will always be prone to
feeling sickening and misguided and we
will self-destructively though
unconsciously set out to repel or
disappoint it it is simply more normal
and bearable to be rejected
if we are at the self-hating end of the
spectrum we should not continue to
imagine that love could be easy even if
the most accomplished person were to
enter our lives indeed especially if
they were to make the error of doing so
are underlying disgust at our own being
would only create a harrowing conflict
we would recognize that another was
offering us their deeper faction but in
the secret folds of our souls we could
only be certain of a mistake or delusion
we would have to reject recoil not
follow up push away and in a thousand
small and large moves ensure that a
lover would eventually have to align
their view of us with our view of
ourselves to begin to counterbalance the
hatred we have to learn to extend
compassion to ourselves for our
self-lacerating impulses and remember
that how we feel about ourselves is we
can be certain a bitter Legacy of how
other people at a formative age viewed
and treated us
the adult process of recovery involves
grasping that we have indeed absorbed
unduly harsh ideas about who we are but
that it is entirely in our power to
begin to counteract them by imagining
how a better caregiver might have
supported us in the past and how a kind
lover might help us in the future an
ideal compassionate figure at the start
would have known never to equate
lovability with perfection they could
have cared for us despite our coming
last in the race our missteps and our
confusions
the phrase self-love misleads us when we
imagine that searching for it would mean
striving to acquire a conceited pompous
view of ourselves true release from
self-loathing tends to be a great deal
more modest we are only after a sane
fair and more accurate perspective on
our ordinary Earthly nature we can with
kindness and Good Humor except that
being silly is entirely normal wasting
opportunities is universal average
sexuality is to be expected self-love
shouldn't be predicated on the
competitive idea that we must pull off
extraordinary Feats of courage or
intelligence true love is only ever The
Compassion of the Fallen for the Fallen
it's the search by one radically
imperfect being to express their
tenderness at the sight of the struggles
and pains of another
we should henceforth allow ourselves
enough self-love to be able to endure a
little kindness